dwight kurt schrute has shown himself to
be at various points both terribly
misguided and an unexpected voice of
reason on the office more often than you
might expect the eccentric beat farmer
and assistant to the regional manager
played by rayne wilson on the classic
nbc sitcom is actually worth listening
to despite his strangeness dwight often
shows a knack for problem solving and
critical thinking that proves
indispensable in the workplace at one
point he brings a spud gun into work in
a duffel bag just to test the office
park's security who else would take that
initiative plus he's all about loyalty
but if there were somewhere else that
valued that loyalty more highly
i'm going wherever they value loyalty
the most
don't think about that one too hard by
all accounts particularly his own dwight
is a force to be reckoned with and an
asset to be paid attention to but the
people around dwight don't regard him
this way very often or at all really
dwight isn't actually treated fairly in
most instances his boss and idol michael
scott repeatedly spurns him both in
terms of friendship and the promotions
dwight craves consider michael's rolodex
entry on dwight which reads simply quote
tall beats might dwight the resident
weirdo of the office be as
underappreciated hero there are many
signs that point to this being true but
something that happens during the office
season 2 really drives this point home
here's the office conflict that has fans
reevaluating dwight and jim of course
nobody wants to dislike the big hero jim
and it is entertaining to watch dwight
swing wildly between oblivious
incompetence frustration and genuine
dominance where he uses his intelligence
to command the situation and the people
in it over time however it's hard not to
notice how often dwight has met with
dismissiveness and even full-on
antagonism no matter how he behaves
that's not to say he doesn't sometimes
instigate problems himself the incessant
prank war between dwight and jim halpert
the time dwight put the entire office in
real danger to prove a point about being
prepared in the event of a fire the
verbal jabs he throws at his fellow
dunder mifflin employees that's just the
tip of the iceberg but the issue is that
dwight isn't always to blame and when he
feels uncomfortable at work and turns to
his company for help he is at best
laughed at at worst he's ignored one of
the worst examples of the lack of
respect dwight gets comes from human
resources representative toby flenderson
in the season 2 episode conflict
resolution the episode sees dwight
approaching toby with some very
legitimate claims about jim's behavior
it's toby's job to hear dwight out
address his concerns appropriately and
resolve the conflict between dwight and
jim unfortunately toby neglects him
sticking all of dwight's complaints in a
box rather than taking them seriously
the office is a comedy of course but if
we're thinking in terms of real-life
companies toby's actions are almost
certainly a violation of procedure and
outside of a professional context it's
just a jerk move as many fans have
pointed out toby kind of lets everyone
down in the episode as it reveals that
he's kept a massive file of unresolved
complaints from dunder mifflin employees
held back but is particularly hard on
dwight who's clearly complained about
jim for years and been ignored basically
every time sure dwight's a lot to handle
on his own but if an employee is that
concerned about a co-worker ignoring it
probably isn't the best response dwight
is visibly distressed by jim's actions
he doesn't find jim's antics funny and
the show doesn't depict their prank war
as harmless fun between friends jim's
behavior messes with dwight's sense of
his own sanity his emotions and his
ability to do his job at one point jim
even tricks him into going into the
women's restroom this adds up to a
textbook hostile work environment but
toby never lifts a finger to do what he
is literally paid to do fans of the
office are now looking back on the
episode and feeling sympathy for dwight
seeing him as a complicated character
who deserves some kindness here
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]